after 82 days underground these wounded
ukrainian soldiers are finally leaving
the azov style steel plant on russian
buses displaying the letter zed symbolic
of its invasion
for months these fighters from the azov
battalion attempted to defend the steel
plant in mariopol and prevent russian
soldiers from completely taking over the
port city but outnumbered and
overpowered ukraine says its mission to
defend the plant is
the over of mario paul fulfilled all the
tasks set by their commanders
unfortunately we do not have the
opportunity to unblock as of style by
military means
the fight for the steelworks and the
plight of civilians and fighters trapped
there captured the world's attention all
women children and elderly have already
been rescued president vladimir zelinsky
says the priority now is to move out the
rest of the fighters still in the plants
thanks to the actions of the ukrainian
military the international committee of
the red cross and the un we hope that we
will be able to save the lives of our
guys there are severely wounded soldiers
among them they've been given care i
want to stress that ukraine needs
ukrainian heroes alive
those seriously wounded have been taken
to a medical facility in the
russian-controlled town of navo azovsk
they could become part of a prisoner
swap
ukrainian fighters say they held out in
avastar for weeks to buy time for the
rest of ukraine to battle russian forces
and secure western arms needed to
withstand russia's assault
but the evacuation marks the end of what
could be one of the longest and most
bloody battles of the ukraine war
mariopol is now in ruins and ukraine
says tens of thousands of people have
died victoria gatenbee al jazeera
[Applause]